as dawn broke on that gradual morning
the greatest Armada ships the world has
ever seen
till the narrow waters of the English
Channel weather sounds very bit rough
there's not a dead paper about the red
eyes then there is no longer an exercise
on the 6th of June 1944 48 commando of
the raw Marines landed on Juno Beach in
Normandy among them my grandfather
Clive Pitt landed on the beach well Jack
to tell you the truth it was a bit of a
disaster we thought we didn't know quite
what was happening it's a long time to
go and unfortunately not many hours left
did any of your friends die there's
three of us sat on the bonnet of the
Jeep
Freddie white dick Simpson and me and
Jerry opened up and dick hit the deck
and let me come to put a field dressing
on him he unfortunately he'd been shot
why you scared yes so scared
if anybody who said they wasn't scared I
think that the person very ran against
withering fire from well concealed
German emplacements only the highest
courage and determination could avail
it's a great honour and the most
emotional moment in my professional life
to remake the French honour to the
British veterans today France wants to
thank you in 2014 on the 70th
anniversary of d-day the French
government announced it would award the
lesion donor its highest order of merit
to all British veterans to thank them
for their bravery in helping liberate
France under new
[Applause]
[Music]
here's the coast of Normandy yes like so
many d-day veterans my grandfather is
now too frail to take part in this
year's Normandy commemorations so Jack
and I made the journey on his behalf
it's a bit different today to how it
would have looked 75 years ago yeah what
do you think granddad would have been
feeling when he was approaching
scared
the memorial stone for d-day and to the
role that was played by the 48 throng
Marine Commandos here look and the North
Shore regiment the Canadian Army yeah
over there yes that the commandos which
died you just want to have a look that's
and that's who he told us about who died
just as they were coming in to land on
the beach didn't he yes pretty sure this
is about where great-granddad landed but
max here is a historian who specializes
in world war ii and d-day we don't know
exactly where but it's somewhere just
here yeah
when they arrived here on the beach do
you know what happened well there were
Germans just over there wait waiting for
them with guns so he went up off up here
in his Jeep yeah with people shooting at
him gonna be hurting from day though
yeah and he was following lots of other
men who were all trying to escape off
the beach up just where we are right now
it's very lucky that he survived yeah
absolutely
do you think lots of people were hurt
here yes how many do you think count
we're standing surrounded by nearly
5,000 British and Commonwealth but also
German servicemen who died during the
Normandy campaign these were great
granddad's colleagues some of them his
friends and people he fought alongside
let's have a look at these Captain James
Perry who died on d-day aged 22 and he
died just after he managed to get off
the beach he was trying to get a line so
that others could get her absol
lately and he drowned with that look
about himself else think about other
people absolutely did you miss your
mummy yeah I was a very young man then
Jack and she said I've been a good lad
Jack can you remember what great
granddad told you he carried in his
pocket all the way through the wall yes
mummy
hmm take care of yourself my lad and
remember I should always be thinking of
the old thing every night all your safe
return at the end of this struggle
whatever I said to you and I have been
cross you know I haven't meant it you
have always been a good lad I have no
fears fears fears for you
so Gerry Onassis get your mother